reality TV's most famous feuding exes
are at it again John and Kate Goff and
of course an Indus exclusive interview
with our Jennifer Karros John drops a
major bombshell about one of his eight
children and attacks the way that Kate
is raising that what's it like we don't
when you talk to your kids what do they
say what's it like living at home with
mom Oh
their life is just chores that's what
they tell me chores yeah their chores
supersede their homework their chores
supersede any activity their chores even
supersede my custody so if they don't
get their toy son they're not coming to
my house Jon Gosselin says his kids are
part of a mind-numbing reality
trainwreck and the newest promo he says
proves it look at the strain they're
just kids do they enjoy filming the show
I think they like the activities they do
but I think she ruins it she ruins like
the fun part of it still this is
actually the kind of reality drama we've
come to expect but is there even more
drama behind the scenes involving son
Collin John who now works part-time as a
DJ claims Colin's whereabouts are a big
mystery I have an idea where he is but I
don't really know kate says that Collin
isn't in a special school for special
needs kids with behavioral problems
that's what she tells the press that's
what she tells the public John claims
law-enforcement officials have not
corroborated Keith's story TLC has
declined to comment and we reached out
to Kate she did not want to comment
either and have you picked up the phone
and tried calling her and saying where
is Collin where is our son I mean I
asked but she doesn't tell me she won't
answer any of my texts unless they
pertain to custody
Wow if you texted Kate right now yeah
where is my second one I wanted to speak
to Jon who lost a legal custody of his
children says he has not seen Collin for
more than a year and a half I've been
wanting to ask you are you ever gonna
tell me we're calling us she won't
respond if Carla is watching this
interview right now maybe yes what would
you tell him
just that I'm been actively looking for
you and right now I'm just gonna go back
to court and your mom will tell me
eventually if it's court-ordered right
now John is working with an attorney
hoping to regain some parental rights
if I get any right I'm not gonna sign
for my kids to film I think that's her
fear that's right here go since you'll
have no income it's like taking your job
away and if you are able to get joint
physical and legal custody will you
allow your children to film on the show
there's two phone calls I'm making one
is to TLC and the other one is to find
out where my son is
that's it so it like to me it's like
there's something being hidden so I
don't know I'll find out when I find
them it's gonna happen
[Music]